Dr Anthony fauci the man who claims that
if you criticize him you are actually
criticizing science itself much like
Emperor Palpatine he went on Stephen
Colbert's show and uh he says that
Ivermectin doesn't work although the CDC
actually does say it does work but some
of the the sort of the
um confusion that came out over the last
few years I think I've asked you about
this but I want to check in more time
did Ivermectin do anything no okay
humans do take it but not for this
purpose right it does not help with
covet and it could be dangerous okay uh
hydroxychloroquine did it do anything no
no so people who hoarded that no no
reason to have done that okay just just
checking just you got it for a friend
got it okay
okay so the CDC does actually say that
Ivermectin helps with covid and there's
all sorts of interesting studies on uh
hcq so let's just put that aside for
just a second and now I want to link
this back to my conversation with Bill
Maher because we actually started
talking about some of the late night
comics and how everything has become so
hyper partisan and that you know in
effect there's a reason that Gutfeld is
crushing it as number one in late night
it's not only because gutfeld's a good
dude and he's funny and the show is
interesting and it's free form and all
that stuff but it's also because these
other guys Colbert Kimmel Etc they've
just become as I put it part of the
machine and that machine loves fauci and
that machine loves control and all of
those things but isn't that crazy that
you're right that all the all the comics
that were supposed to put everybody to
bed or whatever it is they all went
bananas left I mean these guys are
terrible like Kimmel to me is just
[ __ ] you may be friends with him I
know a lot of people
yeah like he's Colbert
yeah like those guys to me they're just
the worst sort of partisan nonsense you
want everybody but the good part of that
is we don't hide it like he doesn't like
me and I don't like him and we don't
deny it and we don't like it no but he's
nothing yeah he's nothing he's very
successful no no but he's just giving
the machine what it wants all the time
you giving you for my differences with
you I totally respect you this is well
said yeah giving the machine What It
Wants I wish I had thought of that
phraseology that's exactly right okay so
giving the machine what it wants that's
what Colbert does he brings out he trots
out all of the Democrats he trots out
all the CDC people all of them and he
tells you how great they are and how
wonderful they are he's a he's a
partisan and a hack working at a
mainstream Network that's just what it
is I was really happy in that moment
that that bill got it right bill again I
have some differences with the guy he's
not giving the machine what it wants if
you want to if Bill was giving the
machine what it wants he would never be
criticizing the walksters he would never
be asking questions about vaccines even
if you think he did it too late even if
you think he's not critical enough of
trump all of those things uh he's too
critical of trump etc etc but then to
prove the point of uh the machine and
Colbert and fauci uh well here's Colbert
and fauci uh just watch this are you
worried at all about the new booster no
no no are you are you worried you're not
worried that the the 5G chip that it
puts in you is going to interfere with
the 3G chip from the last one Bill Gates
and I decided we're going to take the
chips out now we're not going to oh
really oh how used to needles are you
pretty pretty yeah have you had any
Botox because no at 81 you look
fantastic you can't tell me this is
natural
let me know if you need some condoms
I'll ask for you okay oh spooky season
is coming up what scares you the most
thousand kids coming to my door
breathing on me
okay so look there's nothing funny about
that obviously it's canned laughter for
him even to say at the end and I get
he's trying to be funny and he's just
not funny and he's on a non-comedy show
that what really makes him nervous is
kids laugh kids uh breathing on him it's
actually kind of disgusting right it
really is kind of disgusting but he's
vaxxed he just had covet again he's
boosted up the Wazoo he wants all these
kids vaxxed but my my broader point to
bring it to what I was discussing with
Bill is that Colbert is just he's just
part of the machine that there is
nothing honest it will mock and make fun
of everyone who honestly asks questions
or who thinks about things a little bit
differently